Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
El cigarrillo no es bueno para la salud.
Ninguna novedad, pues sus efectos
dañinos se conocen desde hace décadas.
Pero ¿cómo actúa exactamente
para ocasionar ese daño?
Veamos qué sucede cuando
sus componentes ingresan al organismo,
y cuáles son los beneficios físicos
de dejar de fumar definitivamente.
Con cada inhalación,
el humo introduce sus más
de 5000 sustancias químicas,
que entran en contacto
con los tejidos del cuerpo.
El primer efecto se produce cuando
el alquitrán, material negro y resinoso,
empieza a recubrir
los dientes y las encías,
dañando el esmalte dental
y, a la larga, provocando caries.
Con el tiempo, el humo también daña
las terminales nerviosas de la nariz
y ocasiona pérdida del olfato.
Dentro de las vías aéreas y los pulmones,
el humo aumenta el riesgo de infecciones
y de enfermedades crónicas
como la bronquitis y el enfisema.
Esto ocurre porque se dañan los cilios,
pequeñas estructuras piliformes
que mantienen las vías aéreas limpias.
El humo llega luego a los alveolos,
pequeñas bolsas de aire que permiten
el intercambio de oxígeno y dióxido
de carbono entre los pulmones y la sangre.
Un gas tóxico, el monóxido de carbono,
ingresa a la sangre
a través de esa membrana,
se une a la hemoglobina
y desplaza el oxígeno anteriormente
distribuido por ella en todo el organismo.
Esta es una de las razones
por las que fumar
puede causar falta de oxígeno
y dificultad para respirar.
En el término de 10 segundos,
el flujo sanguíneo transporta al cerebro
un estimulante llamado nicotina,
y de este modo se libera dopamina
y otros neurotransmisores
como las endorfinas,
que dan sensación de placer
y hacen del tabaquismo
un hábito altamente adictivo.
La nicotina y otras sustancias
presentes en el cigarrillo
contraen simultánemente
los vasos sanguíneos
y dañan su delicado
revestimiento endotelial,
restringiendo así el flujo de sangre.
Estos efectos vasculares engrosan
las paredes de los vasos sanguíneos
y aumentan la viscosidad
de las plaquetas de la sangre,
favoreciendo la formación de coágulos
y la propensión a ataques
cardíacos e infartos.
Muchas sustancias químicas del cigarrillo
pueden ocasionar peligrosas mutaciones
en el ADN de nuestro organismo
y favorecer el desarrollo del cáncer.
Además, sustancias
como el arsénico y el níquel
pueden entorpecer el proceso
de reparación del ADN,
y comprometer así la capacidad del cuerpo
para combatir distintos tipos de cáncer.
De hecho, una de cada tres muertes
producidas por cáncer en EE. UU.
se debe al tabaquismo.
Pero el fumar no produce
cáncer de pulmón únicamente.
También puede causar cáncer
en numerosos tejidos y órganos,
e incluso dañar la vista
y debilitar los huesos.
Dificulta la posibilidad
de embarazo en la mujer
y, en los hombres, puede
causar disfunción eréctil.
Pero para quienes dejan de fumar,
los ventajas son notablemente positivas,
con beneficios físicos
casi inmediatos y duraderos.
Apenas transcurridos 20 minutos
del último cigarrillo de un fumador,
el ritmo cardíaco y la presión arterial
comienzan a retornar a la normalidad.
Luego de 12 horas, los niveles
de monóxido de carbono se estabilizan,
permitiendo un mayor transporte
de oxígeno en la sangre.
Transcurrido un día,
el riesgo de ataque cardíaco disminuye
al normalizarse la presión
sanguínea y el ritmo del corazón.
A los dos días,
las terminales nerviosas
que se encargan del gusto y el olfato
empiezan a recuperarse.
Los pulmones mejoran su función
al cabo de un mes aproximadamente,
con disminución de la tos
y menos dificultad para respirar.
Los delicados cilios piliformes
de las vías aéreas y de los pulmones
comienzan a recuperarse en semanas,
y se reparan a los nueve meses,
mejorando la resistencia a infecciones.
Al cabo de un año sin fumar,
el riesgo de enfermedad
cardíaca se reduce a la mitad,
pues los vasos sanguíneos
mejoran su funcionamiento.
Transcurridos cinco años,
la formación de coágulos
se reduce notablemente
y el riesgo de infarto sigue en declive.
A los diez años, la posibilidad
de desarrollar cáncer de pulmón terminal
disminuye un 50 %,
quizá porque la habilidad
del cuerpo para reparar el ADN
vuelve a recuperarse.
A los 15 años, la posibilidad
de desarrollar enfermedades coronarias
es básicamente la misma
que la de un no fumador.
Pero nada de esto es fácil de lograr.
Dejar de fumar puede derivar
en ansiedad y depresión
por abstinencia de nicotina.
Pero, afortunadamente,
los efectos suelen ser temporarios,
y dejar de fumar es cada vez más fácil
gracias a un arsenal de herramientas
cada vez más nutrido.
El reemplazo de la nicotina
por gomas de mascar,
parches cutáneos,
pastillas
y aerosoles
pueden ser terapias
de ayuda para dejar el hábito.
Estas terapias estimulan los receptores
de la nicotina en el cerebro
y de ese modo previenen
los síntomas de abstinencia,
sin el agregado de otras
sustancias químicas nocivas.
La asistencia psicológica
y los grupos de apoyo,
las terapias cognitivo conductuales
y la actividad física moderada
también pueden ayudar
a los fumadores a dejar el cigarrillo.
Es una muy buena noticia,
pues dejar de fumar nos reencamina
por la senda de la salud.